hello everyone thanks for coming
um my name is stephen naren and i'm the
director of the fortune of video archive
for holocaust testimony and
testimonies and it's my pleasure to host
this event marking the 10th anniversary
of the publication of
an wonderful book the wonder of their
voices the 1946 holocaust interviews of
david boder
published by oxford university press in
december of 2010.
today we're delighted to be joined by
the author alan rosen
who will illuminate us about the history
and ongoing significance of david boder
and his interview project
as well as representatives from the
illinois institute of technology
the institution from which voter
launched his interview project in 1946
adam strohm and mindy pew adam and mindy
help manage the boater collection and
its online repository voices from the
holocaust and they'll give us some
background about
their effort to make the boater
collection accessible and a current
joint project with the fortune off video
archive to make
two collections co-searchable uh but
before i hand things over to alan
um he asked me to say a few words about
how i view the relationship between the
fortunate
boater collections and how these two
very different pioneering projects
separated by decades share some common
some commonalities i'll begin with a a
reading of a memorandum
boater wrote in may 1945 it was his
preliminary plan for
for the effort to record dps in europe
much of it unsurprisingly
resonates with the approach taken
decades later by the fortunate
archives predecessor organization called
the holocaust survivors film project or
hsfp
which began in 1979. are five bullet six
bullet points
and they go something like this there
needs to be the technical know-how to
record human speech
the victims should be recorded in their
own language in their own words for
psychological and historical reasons
the victim's many exotic languages make
it impossible for journalists to do the
job competently
a psychologist must get the stories of
all the participants
the recordings can be used for
documenting the war and for educating
americans and europeans
and six times of the essence since
memory and emotion
fades immediately it's hard to ignore
more than a few significant similarities
between the hsfp and voter's memorandum
firstly the importance of the use of
technology to do this work rosen in his
book writes this clearly applies to the
fortune of archive that i quote
the history of holocaust testimonies has
been bound up with technology
with technological advance and
obsolescence as a means to document or
record testimony
end quote yiddishist max weinreich
called boater's idea to record
interviews a happy idea
this idea was followed decades later by
a group of survivors and allies in new
haven
who once again embraced new
technological advances to continue
the work that had come before it was
another happy idea
in the service of documenting an unhappy
subject
survivors in their own words this time
on video
recorded in the tenuous after of the
ongoing aftermath of the holocaust
some of the other bullet points in
boater's memorandum also ring true
another one is the desire to tell the
story of the holocaust through the words
of the survivors themselves to provide
them a space to use their authentic
voice
there's also a recognition of the
necessity of expertise to do this type
of work
both linguistic expertise and a deep
understanding of the cultural context of
the survivor
something that both voter and as a
european emigre
and the survivors in the new haven
community could provide they were
themselves no strangers to the european
experience
there's also a shared understanding of
the inadequacy of a strictly
journalistic approach
the importance of a psychological
framing and a recognition of the role of
trauma
an approach also taken by one of the
fortune of archives founders dori lao
dory himself a child survivor from
chernowitz did groundbreaking work in
trauma studies had a psychological
practice in new haven
and brought his own personal and
professional experiences to the project
the memorandum boaters membrane
also foresees the value of these
materials for historical research and
other disciplines
not exclusively historical research
their potential documentation as well as
education
and finally there is this brutal
recognition of the teeth of time
even more acute for the pioneers the
fortune of video archive starting in
1979
after so many survivors had already died
boeder himself was a psychologist and
like laub saw himself as i quote
offering a service that others behalf on
the
uh working on behalf of the dps could
not provide
after all there were dozens of
organizations geared to alleviating the
privations of the present
and assisting with rehabilitation
but boater and laub felt that
psychological tools and approaches
needed to be the motor of these
these efforts moreover both boater and
fortunate's founders felt that many
previous attempts to document to
represent the holocaust were inadequate
in boater's day he was reacting in part
to the work of
uh film crews soviet british american
the images that played in movie houses
around the world
featured silent footage from the camps
for instance mydonic liberated before
the end of the war by the soviets and
filmed by roman carmen and others
voters saw this cinematic approach as a
failure
to document the european tragedy in its
full form
alan quotes in his book quotes a passage
from jorge semprin
uh his account of the account of
watching newsreels in 45
and he allen says that semprin's words
really echo boater's own notebooks
semprin wrote and i quote what was
really needed was commentary on the
images
to decipher them to situate them not
only in historical context
but within the continuity of emotions
and in order to remain as close as
possible to the actual experiences
this commentary would have to be spoken
by the survivors themselves end quote
boeder would seek to provide this
commentary this soundtrack using
his wire recorder and if boater's work
was in part counter cinematic
so was the fortune off video archive it
too is established as a means to
counter prevailing representations of
the holocaust and their failures
in particular around the time of the
founding of the hsfp
survivors cite their distaste for the
docudrama holocaust released in 1978
as a catalyst for this new video
recording effort to set the record
straight
their goal was to let survivors tell
their story and their own words like
boater
and i think professor hartman would
agree after all
he called video testimony a new genre of
documentation
that was and i quote cinematic encounter
cinematic
at the same time uh that quotes from
uh hartman's article the cinema animal
on spielberg schindler's list if you
want to read more
one important difference between fortune
off and boater was the scope of the
interviews
boater aimed to produce what he called
topical autobiographies
he was focused on a topical historical
event the war and its impact
his goal was not to record a complete
life story fortunately by contrast felt
it was essential
to begin with survivors earliest
memories capturing first-hand accounts
of what came before the war
fortunate feels that one cannot grasp
the losses of the war without knowing
what came prior
as well as the events of the post-war
period and the re-establishment of lives
and new homelands
nevertheless oder's use of the term
autobiography underscores an important
kinship with the survivor that is shared
by boater and fortuneof
there is an emphasis on agency in the
term autobiography
after all boater didn't say he didn't
call them topical biographies
drafted by a spilled skilled biographer
on on their behalf
rather the idea was to use technological
tools to provide the common man and
woman with a chance to record their own
autobiographical accounts again in their
own words
in his notebook spotter wrote that when
he met with potential interviewees
they would often seek to provide him
with the most exceptional and unusual
stories
voter would protest and tell them that
he wanted and i quote
wanted the rank and file experience not
the usual story
not the unusual story for a boater the
goal was to produce a broad
record of dissimilar groups of
individuals a wide-ranging mosaic of
stories from the war
a goal the fortunate archive also shares
boeder hoped the resulting interviews
would help explain to a naive american
public what the unnamed masses of dps
languishing in europe had experienced
in doing so he had motives beyond his
own academic interest of studying trauma
there was hope that these stories could
convince the american public to open
their gates to further immigration
but beyond his political motivation
there was also a keen sense of an
ethnographic
impetus in voters work this is best
demonstrated in voters many recordings
of songs
sung by dps capturing these songs and
voters opinion was the ideal proof for
the value of the oral recording method
only audio or video in the case of
fortune off can capture songs
adequately or as one commenter on the
voter collection said
it was a way quote to do justice to the
oral dimension of the victim's
experience
once again this aspect of oral recording
process the oral recording process is a
common thread between both the work of
voter and fortunate
archive in a way they both mirror
previous jewish ethnographic efforts
like those of shenanski and the interwar
period or the historical commissions
and voters recordings and fortune of
testimonies therefore also share a sort
of longer legacy
of a seemingly endless effort by
practitioners of jewish
quote unquote salvage ethnology
serge katrinsky one of these salvage
ethnographers who recorded music among
dps after the war
says it so quote the song is the juice
from ghettos death camps and partisans
sang from their sad hearts will be a
great contribution to the history of
jewish martyrdom
and struggle the songs present the daily
jewish life in the ghettos with all its
accompanying phenomena like arrests
death gestapo jewish
power mongers internal way of life etc
it's all reflected
in precisely in this bloody folklore
i will note as an aside that the video
archive continues to
explore the elements of poetry and song
in its testimonies
and then we have an ongoing project in
fact that's being led by our musician
and resident cecil slupovic
slovich and you can learn more about
that project on
our website songsfromtestimonies.org
finally and this is like the most
obvious connection between boater and
the fortune of archive is their position
as post-war projects
they both share the rubric of belated
testimony
fortunately obviously more so than voter
belated testimony is often judged
quite differently in terms of value and
accuracy when compared to wartime
testimony
but even boeder was aware of a lack of
immediacy in his recording project
despite it
already beginning in 1946 for boater
in a way he had already started too late
months had passed since liberation and
this would indubitably alter
the type of story survivors would tell
still aboder persisted in his effort as
he saw the work as
essential he recognized belatedness as a
fact
but he didn't feel that the work was
necessarily less important than
that of other groups like shabbos who
documented the holocaust slow burn in
media res
in ghettos and camps it was just
different
the fortunate archive shares this view
despite its much
more belated belatedness
and again later did not mean worse it
just meant different
more importantly in voter's perspective
from boater's perspective the boundaries
between wartime and post-war
between before and after are less clear
than one would expect
and i believe and we have larry langer
on uh
here with us today i believe that larry
langer and robert kraft two scholars who
spent an extraordinary amount of time
listening to and studying video
testimony would probably agree with him
they also found that the core of
traumatic memory persists
and that there is often some sort of
bifurcation between deep memory and
common memory the sense of the survivor
leading two lives a normal life and a
life
back there simultaneously and as rosen
puts it out quickly in his book
the boundary between the past and the
present is porous
and i quote since survivors in the
aftermath of the war
have not yet subjectively experienced a
true
after hence testimony after the war
mirrored testimony
during it these are just a few of the
most obvious
commonalities and breaks that i see
between the boater and fortune off
collections
they truly are like cousins divided by
time and space
share many goals and traits this is why
it's so edifying for us to be able to
provide a venue for revisiting allen's
work today
and to publicly discuss with mindy and
adam the ongoing
joint effort to bring fortune the
fortune off archive and the voter
collections
together so with that let's move on to
our
main event um our first speaker
alan rosen allen is an impressive
scholar with over a dozen
books in a new innumerable other
publications for instance
allen was the editor of literature of
the holocaust
and elie wiesel jewish literary and
moral perspectives his latest book
is the holocaust jewish calendars
keeping time sacred
making time holy which came out in 2019
that book was awarded the yad vashem
international book prize
he has taught at universities colleges
yeshivas and seminaries in israel and
the united states
and lectures regularly on literature and
testimony at yad vashem's international
school for holocaust studies
he's a native of los angeles he studied
under
elie wiesel in boston and now lives in
jerusalem
and we're delighted to have him here
alan
you have the floor
50 years ago
in a different interview project
a mr slutsky
described how as a boy
a teenage boy he came back from work
at the ghetto one day found that his
sister
had been taken in a roundup
mad with grief he ran
and uh to the
headquarters of the enemy
and audaciously
foolishly dangerously demanded that he
sits sister be released
they laughed at him and then the head of
the
headquarters came out
and would they er
with a mean
uh approach to
slutsky said i'll let her go
if you grow hair
on your on the palm of your hand
mr slitsky then raised up his palm
which was covered with hair
the enemy commander
furious grabbed the girl through her
back to the boy and shouted that they
they run out
they were demons mr slitzky as he
recounts this
says that what had caused the hair to
grow
[Music]
was an accident that had taken place
as a younger boy
and a skin graft had come from
he said a hairy part of his body
the uh and then with a
uh a witty sense
of fortune said that the doctors
told him that this was impossible
that a hairy part of the body grafted
onto the palm
should continue to grow hair
but he says that
my hand never went to medical school
so it didn't know that it was supposed
to
follow those rules
in a similar vein boater came early
before he had a chance to
have to weather what were seemingly
the claims that the
survivors spoke in
what is called being called a
anti-redemptive way
so as i write at the end of my book
which i'm beginning with here voter
believed in closure
and more over enclosure of a certain
kind
at the very end of his compilation of 16
volumes 300 3163
pages entitled topical autobiographies
at the very bottom of the page he had
printed
in hebrew script the word khazak
a flourish that was both surprisingly
conventional
and strikingly innovative boater
knew well what he was doing
the three cryptic letters at the end he
wrote to his friends
francis and maggie coughlin in 1957
allowing the german k
to creep into his otherwise admirable
english spelling
are the hebrew word meaning be
strong and they are imprinted at the
end of each book
of the torah
i then perhaps can show
here at the end of this
uh amish where i'm pointing my
finger it doesn't have to be seen in
a very uh
clear way but clear enough
to be able to know that at the end of
every
sacred jewish book that
kazakh is written just as
it's at the end when we finish one of
the five books of moses
the in the synagogue we call out
be strong be strong and be strengthened
so that voter was here
pointing to a fact that he saw at the
end of his 10 years
or so of of doing the
interviews of uh processing the
interviews
bringing them out in a book in 1949
i did not interview the dead
and then spending six years
on his topical autobiography that he
saw this under the rubric of torah
and the closure that he brought at the
end was to have it exist
as such which did not in any way
mean that the testimony that he
brought with the inn was
anything less than devastating to read
and
listen to but at the same time
that it had a for him
sacred dimension the second
comment to introduce my remarks
is that it was approached a few days ago
by an author of children's books
who would like to render
individual child's book voters
interview project so he asked me
queried me what what did i think would
be the most
important aspect to bring
forth in such book
and i responded the fact
that someone was not so young
59 years old would travel halfway around
the world
to listen to people tell
stories of very difficult times
that act of listening which boater did
again and again and again not
only in the interview project itself in
europe
but as he transcribed the recordings
over the next 10 years
that he listened again and again
and again and that strikes me
as a avenue
to point children to
who are perhaps often taught
about public speaking but maybe
not as much about public lists me
the third introductory comment has to do
with
10 years it's been 10 years since my
book was published
and in the world in general 10 years
scene is a decade defining time
um we know that it carries perhaps even
deeper meaning within
jewish tradition the ten commandments
in the hasidic tradition we talk about
the ten
powers of the soul that emerge
and we've heard even in a little bit
that i've said that
ten years were important intervals for
david boder
in his project when once he
once he was able to
go to europe and uh undertake to
interview um from that point forward
he spent virtually the next 10 years
non-stop in trying to
find every avenue to bring forth
these interviews to a public who he felt
were deserving of not only
the superficial encounters
with the those who were murdered
or those who had survived that were
in the motion picture cinemas at that
time but rather
to hear the stories of each and
each individual
different as they were jew and non-jew
child and elderly and everyone
in between interviewing in some
nine languages
so those that 10-year period he also had
migrated to the united states in 1926
so it was a 20-year period that passed
before he went on his
uh expedition as he called it to europe
and so in thinking about 10 years
there are many different meanings that
coincide and it felt to me
that it was worthwhile to take stock of
what had taken placed during that
those those years since the publication
of my book
to see in what way it
had perhaps had some effect
um and that's i'll comment on
a on those aspects here
uh today uh tonight in
jerusalem it's pushing 9 30
at night in jerusalem so
we're we're sharing many time zones here
thank you all for joining and thanks
especially to stephen
aaron who has convened us
here and done so much to
provide wonderful uh
programming at the fort north archive
succeeding uh joanne rudolph
who herself had done extraordinary
programming and accomplishments there
and were fortunate to have them
and also i had suggested that we might
bring on board
the representatives of the illinois
institute of technology
whose voices the holocaust
website which is currently being
rebuilt we look forward to its launch
but
in the time in the approximately
15 years um or so
of its being up and running um
has been a really set the standard
to my mind for all uh
interview projects and providing excess
direction
in depth that allows one to do
work with listening to
the interviews um in both
original language and in translation
so we look forward to adam and
adam strom and mindy bq's remarks that
will follow
mine uh
thanks again
first um then uh
to mention that since the publication
people one of the
uh aspects that has been surprisingly
emphasized to me has been voters work as
an
archive unto itself um
i don't think i thought of it that way
at the time but at least two major
conferences one of which i gave the
keynote address
the adversary have
invited me to speak about boater's work
in that way
and i think what it does is
to provide us with the sense of the
enormous depth and depth and scope
of voters interviewing that would
have it be its own independent
archive and i'll say more about that at
the
end when i give a short list of those
uh projects that i think could be done
to take bolder's work to
even a further stage and hope that that
will
be taken up and happen in the near
future
the second has been the technological
aspect voters
keen sense of bringing a wire recorder
to interview which was
is so astonishingly uh
seemingly unduplicated had
wine like as steven aaron had mentioned
speak about his a happy idea
and then say it was the only thing was
that it was surprising that no one else
had done it
and especially striking since there
was the use of recording
uh in europe at the same time
in the dp centers but to record
exclusively songs and not uh
interviews so that that technological
side has been of keen interest
at the university of luxembourg had a
team
of researchers who have made a
model digital lesson of stoves studying
the holocaust and also studying the
uh various stages through boaters
which voters were went through in
um in uh
in looking at the significance of what
they call source
digital criticism i think for
all that that voters
efforts ended up being most uh
strongly dedicated to print um
which is an irony of course because we
celebrate his uh he's making the
recordings
but he ended up to see
that the circulating the print
in both his book and
in the 16 volumes of topical
autobiographies
which he himself paid to send to
libraries throughout the world
that that was a way to be able to
bring the um interviews
uh into circulation and to the notice of
a
range of different academics and
not academics alike
with that aspect of print
has been the publication
of voter's book
in a german translation which i was one
of the
editors with of along with julia feist
and uh in verna zollers which came out
i think around 2013
and um
it's it was
its success limited though it was was
very striking a review was written in a
major
german paper which caused it at least
for a short time to be
something of a best seller and
more than that was the voters
on voter's wish list was to have
the book be translated into german
so we by doing that fulfilled
what was one of boater's goals and he
felt that
germany because they had been the
perpetrators were in need
above perhaps more than anyone
of reading what these interviewees had
said
regarding their experience
and so that that has been
a a very uh
a very rich dimension
um one of the
goals i think would be to bring
boater's original english edition
into greater circulation
whether as a book to be published which
i had already tried on one level to do
and
we decided not to go ahead with that
project
for various good reasons but another way
would be to
put the book on a website and
that would allow a far greater
readership and also availability to
researchers
than the limited availability of the
book
now allows and it's not just
having the uh eight
interviews four men four women
perfectly balanced in that respect as
well as many
others to be known in a greater way
but it is also voter's uh striking
transient introduction his commentary
short but very revealing
on each interview um to be
able to be that much
better known it
could be done with taking the
fine commentary that went into the
french edition
that i had the privilege of doing with
my colleague
uh farah brayard and
uh with his historical commentary then
being
translated into english or other
languages
that would help to uh bring the
historical aspect of wrote his word to
another level
voter was not a historian but was rather
a psychologist who as stephen
had mentioned was very dedicated
also to ethnography
so one of the most central
ethnographic dimensions of his
interview were was to collect
songs in the place of song
he began uh who
at the dp centers he tells us
uh with songs by asking those who
he met with um initially
to sing songs that they knew from the
war from before the war
and that that would loosen them up
and then during the recording sessions
he
was always intentive
to asking about the songs
and having them sung
and about midway through
was so taken by what he heard of these
songs
that he then
orchestrated separate song
sessions it seems
that if we're to really capture
the ethnographic genius
of boater's work we need to
have those songs not only
available as they are
in part on a website for ort
and in a smaller way on the holy ghost
museum of washington's website
but to bring them together with the
interviews
because if they exist in separate realms
then we've lost voter as a
non-ethnographer
and we've lost the sense that the
testimony
that he sought listen to
solicited also came in the form of
song that that was testimony
no less than the narrative testimony
that he heard
so that would be a goal that has not yet
been realized but we
hope that both iit and yale will
strive to do that and hope to confirm
further
on that side of boater's
accomplishment voter was
through and through a psychologist
he went to undertake these
interviews as a professional
psychologist
in the first 15 interviews he used
in the majority of them the thematic a
perception
test and in that way presented
his credentials as psychologists
he eventually jettisoned that test
because
it took up too much time he had to
hear other kinds of
recountings but it revealed him
as the psychologist who is interested
as he formulated on the impact
of catastrophe on personality
and devising
as a result of that what he called the
traumatic inventory
there has been some follow-up to
boater's
psychological work myself and my
colleague who i think is here today neil
lipsetz
have recently authored a
an article to that effect and i've
written some
others and there there have been
there has been attention paid but
voters the actual
project seen through a psychological
lens
whole cloth i don't think has been
pursued part of that is of course
because
the archives that would allow that to be
seen in context
are not all together there's one
archive in akron ohio at the
american association of the history of
psychology and other
ucla some papers in
the horror the the whole husband same in
washington
others in yad vashem
so that voters
decision to go on this
expedition motored by
his uh concerns of psychologists
will it need to be taken to even a
further step in the chapter
i gave it uh in my book
um and and i think what
it would bring is a sense of being
able to further clarify why
boater saw language in the
evidence of trauma that was in language
as such essential concern
so that he would
he would only publish the
printed versions of the interviews
with the broken language even in
translation
that he felt had been the result
of the experience during the war
that that dimension still needs to be
brought out in a way i think to
for us to appreciate the depth
of the scars
that were left during the war
and continued on after
what has also come is the
uh popularization of boater's work
not only in the project of a
child's book which is hopefully going to
come
but also in several radio programs dad
of bbc
and nbr also in a novel by
elliott perlman published in 2011
um called the the street sweeper
where as a novelist will do he took
liberties um to
uh make the story a compelling one
as if it seems to me boater's story
wasn't compelling enough in its
uh facts but he had
a good deal of success but in a way
uh left the a larger
swap the public with a misrepresentation
of boeder as a loner who had
engineered this project on his own
with the with the
uncaring responses of those who would
not support him
and what i found and nothing could be
farther
from the truth voter was constantly
supported
by friends family colleagues
academics the worldwide he was
funded for the 10 years he worked on the
project
by the national institute of mental
health
who saw his work as being
is being certainly worth supporting
in every respect and it goes
on from there most
recently is a is a very
intriguing offshoot of the
popularization
has been a film done
on the boater's daughter elena
voter who was a pediatrician
who made striking breakthroughs
in diagnosing a
very terrible child's illness but
allowed it to be
treated in a better way and also
an uh a path breaker pioneer
in dealing with dyslexia
and this
brings to the fore voter's biography
but unfortunately the historical
backdrop is misrepresented
facts are wrong um
and what we have a boater's life
is only also
backdrop and we're still waiting
i think for the the kind of
popularization
if it's to come that will deal with
voter
as uh as his
uh life story which is transparent
virtually in every respect and
extraordinary in its epic dimensions
uh really deserves
a uh
aspect of the project that has been
dealt with
but hopefully we'll receive more
is the re-interviewing of voter
interviewees
that was done in the at the
united states holocaust museum in
washington
under the directorship of john
ringelheim with the help of elizabeth
hedlin from approximately 2002
to uh mainly i think
around 2007 just as i was
getting off of the ground and working on
the project so it's a
great help to me and these interviews
are wonderfully available on the
museum's website um 10 of them
and along with the transcriptions
um in either
english as most of the original
interviewing
was done or in the case of several
hebrew
interviews with an english translation
um just a a
aspect to show what is possible
that's uh brought to us by way of
sharon uh sharon kangas or cohen's
book testimony and time which is
a is a uh first book
really on the re-interviewing
she brings the interview
that david bowder did with gert
a zilber bard where he arrives
at uh bear canal and
boater says yes now and tell me how what
happened in the first
two hours after the train had arrived in
the auschwitz
so gert zillerbard says we were all we
were all unloaded from the car
and immediately a loud voice called
women men
women left men to the right i stood with
the men
in the dark i had we had arrived late in
the evening
and it was already very dark
beginning of march it was dark and i had
lost
track of father and mother and saw no
member of my family anymore
boater so you were saying that
immediately immediately you did not see
your father anymore
either kurt silverberg no
i did not see any of my family anymore
that's from his interview of summer
1946 in german
and interviewed in australia in 2006
the interviewer says so you arrived
in in did you did you how did you know
you were in
auschwitz gert zillerbard who
then has changed his name to groot
silver i i found out later
i didn't know where i was when we when
we disembarked
but i found out fairly soon afterwards
where i was
when we arrived we were asked to leave
the wagons
there was an ss man on a podium and they
said
women and children to the left and men
to the right
and i instinctively held on to my mother
and joined her
and my sister to women to the left where
the women and the children were
and then my mother pushed me
to the men so i think
she really gave birth to me twice
once in 1928
and another time in 1943
my sister and my mother went straight
to the gas chambers so this
re-interviewing
then allows gert silverbard
to not only render
a chronicle of what happened on arrival
but to reinterpret for
us his own sentiments that have come
after some
60 years later when
he looks back on that
that event and can see himself
twice born as i move to the conclusion
in a
translation as we just heard there
from german to english
the attention translation
that i looked at in the section of my
book
has been really secondary
even though i think voter it was primary
voter
as i comment for his work in los angeles
on the transcriptions felt that
he himself was out of his league
and hired bernard wolff
polish jewish survivor to do the
translation
from yiddish polish
german to i think it was
some 27 interviews
so being able to see
what was involved with that
move to a translation
that had to be done by a survivor
seeing it from inside and bold boater
yielding the floor and our way of
thinking of translation there have been
a number of books done on
holocaust studies and translation
but i think this is moving to a
dimension
of voter's work that has been
largely overshadowed by other concerns
the bringing together of the boater
archive into the fort north
merging them together is i think
path-breaking
it realizes what i think jeffrey hartman
and dory loud
would have celebrated story loud when he
was made aware of the voter interviews
was so overwhelmed
by what he talked about as being the
rawness
and our discussions were one of the most
moving
aspects of the work on the boater
interviews for me
so having the boater families find the
second home in yale is extraordinary
so finally to the
two dudes besides those that i've been
interested in
would be perhaps to follow in boater's
footsteps
to take the expedition again for some
enterprising uh younger soul
or perhaps not so younger soul to go to
each of the centers in
france italy switzerland germany
which of course no longer there but the
simple retracing
may be able to unleash a sense of
perspective
of what voter was doing that
we still haven't been able to see
axel dassman the german researcher with
great dedication to boater's work has
done some of that
but it still is there to continue
in addition to bringing out an available
uh into an available venue a
boater's book i did not interview the
dead i think we need to do
that with his two major articles
we need to do that with uh the
if possible his 16 volume
topical autobiography
in in that way that
the boater library will be
open the boater archives has been done
to
end i'll end with uh
what i've been ending most of my
lectures
with on boater which is a story that
tries to bring into perspective
the
more
more overarching meaning
and i'll tell it in the shortest way
possible
in about something over 200 years ago
there was a rabbi schneider zalman of
lyadi who was imprisoned
in saint petersburg
during the time the warden found out
that they had a scholar there
and came to see the rabbi to ask if he
could
um he could ask them a question about
the bible
rabbi said of course so the ra the
warden asked in the book of genesis we
find that
after uh adam and eve ate from the
forbidden fruit they ran to hide behind
a
bush and god
the book of genesis tells us
came into the garden
and and called out
ayeka where are you so the warden
asked the rabbi what kind of
what kind of proposition is this god
who's all seen
who's omniscient can is calling out
where are you he can't see them behind
the bush
that they're hiding so the rabbi says to
the warden
do you believe that the bible is an
eternal book
yes sir the warden who was a religious
christian
do you believe that that it pertains to
each and every one of us
today yes said the warden so the rabbi
says i'll tell you what
god was saying when he called out ayaka
where are you
he was saying to adam and eve where are
you
not where are you hiding but now that
you've
enacted this deed which has changed
the face of all the world where are you
in your course of life
so as i end with this story
in lecturing i say this
is what these interviews are saying to
us
hayek where are you
you've heard my interview and for most
of them we know
they never gave consent that their
interviews should be listened to
or read we are
presuming that prerogative
so given that we have taken that course
where are you what does this mean to you
that you've heard
what i've told you about my ordeal
how has your life been altered
forever thanks very much
thank you alan um we're
i i noticed that a few people are
putting in questions you should feel
free to
to um add questions to the q a button at
the bottom of your screen or in the chat
and we'll get to them
after um our next two presenters
finish um we are now joined
by um adam strom and
mindy pugh who are both representing
the uh paul v galvin library at the
illinois institute of technology in
chicago
both of whom have worked closely with
making the voter collection readily
accessible
to the research community adam is the
director of university archives
and special collections at at the
library at iit
and he received his mslis
from the university of mlas from the
university of illinois at
urbana-champaign
mindy pew is a university archivist and
the campus historian
at the paul v galvin library previously
employed as an archivist and a public
historian at the chicago history museum
mindy not only supports research
projects within the archives but across
campus
teaching history in the humanities
department and
many received a phd from the university
of chicago
so i'm going to hand it over to to you
mindy and adam
i think mindy's going to talk first
about
the uh history of the project mindy i
think you are
still uh your camera is still muted
there okay thank you
um stephen thank you uh um alan
uh for your your great great work in
this
um what i'm going to do is uh is speak
about
iit's relationship with dr
boeder and his work uh and put that in
context
uh i'm very much a historian i do things
very chronologically which i think is
you know kind of a good foundation and
reference point for people moving
forward
to say very very briefly um dr voter
arrived at
lewis institute which is one of the two
predecessor schools of iit
in 1927 uh and
remained at louis until it merged with
another
school predecessor school to create iit
in 1940
and then he was at iit until 1952.
i won't rehearse um the the
chronology of the project i think that's
pretty much pre-knowledge for most of
you who are attending this conference
um he retired from iit in 1952
um not in a great
relational posture with the with iit
um i've seen documentation indicate that
he
left rather dissatisfied uh perhaps a 10
month
10 a month pension was part of it
but after he left iit in 1952 his ties
uh were pretty much all in the past uh
at that point
he went on to have more productive
relationships obviously
after that in 1952 onward with ucla
uh his continuing relationship with the
psychology museum in akron
um which dated back to the 1930s uh
that continued and of course then he
developed ties in
israel as well and those were
his is moving forward points of
reference
that said uh iit's legacy is still
very important um but for us it's been a
process of
rediscovery it's not any continuous
connection with him either personally
or or in terms of his work since 1952
we've had to
also rediscover dr boater and what he
meant
and what he means to this day iit went
through a
tough financial time in the 1970s and
1980s
to the point after the economic downturn
of the early 1990s there was
quite an open question as to whether the
whether iit would even continue as an
institution
or whether it should move to say dupage
county
uh fortunately in the mid 1990s a number
of
prominent individuals bob galvin
of motorola and bob stepped forward
to offer matching funds and iit was
basically reborn
in the mid-1990s as part of that rebirth
and that recommitment to its south side
campus at 35th and state
and its rediscovery of its heritage so
that it could truly anchor
and be reborn in its old location
it started to as a corporation take a
much more serious look at history and
the institutional history
the university archives which had gone
into a period of obeying
during that latter part of the crisis
years was reborn in 1998
uh and galvin library um
entered into a more dynamic period of
trying to promote institutional history
from the late 1990s onward
i can't speak about iit without
mentioning two individuals
at galvin library in that context in the
1990s
for whom the boater project owes a great
deal
the first is christopher stewart uh
christopher stewart
was hired at galvin library in the
mid-1990s
to spearhead moving the card catalog to
digital and also
to promote web developments early you
know efforts to
move into the electronic era and very
closely associated with him was
kristen stendard who's still there
kristin is the
associate dean for administration those
two spearheaded
a lot of the forward-thinking projects
that would move
galvan library into the 21st century
and christopher and um
kristen um at a point in the late 1990s
when they are
um looking for projects to uh to put
online
and and to create sort of a web presence
for galvan library and for iit
um and tried some sort of preliminary
efforts
uh but then they were clued into the
existence or reminded or
indeed informed about david boder and
his legacy
by the psychology department dr ellen
mitchell who is
head of that college of psychology at
iit in the late 1990s
she had happened upon galvin library's
copy
of the voter transcripts from the 1950s
and they had always been there but she
saw it as something of a rediscovery
in terms of alerting her to this
important
person in the history of her own college
of psychology at iit
and um she she very quickly
liaisoned with christopher stewart uh in
terms of
creating a web presence for these
rediscovered
transcriptions and uh so this is
after a period of you know over 40 years
where i t
basically lost sight of david boder that
there's a rediscovery of this legacy and
it's an iit legacy in large part
that this synergy
and rivalry to a certain degree between
the college of psychology
and galvin library emerges but it has
great product um in 1998 1999
uh kristen standart and christopher
stewart negotiate with
library of congress to obtain a
copy set of the library of congress's
wires
so that iit could
return to itself voters interviews audio
files
and they i believe um put 12
of those audio interviews on the initial
voices site which i think was
inaugurated in 1999
and then they put up about 40 to 50 of
the
transcripts now this is before ocr
character recognition was very effective
so stuart and standard involved
a large portion of the staff at galvin
library in
re-entering those transcripts so that
they could be put
online uh i hear to this day testimony
from
various of the staffers there who
survived from that era
who said that how interesting but also
how traumatizing it was
uh to have to enter in every last word
of
from those transcripts um the upside of
that it was certainly a
community all hands on deck thing and a
real
re-uh introduction of the voter legacy
into galvan library through that that
whole process
um christopher stewart went on to become
library dean
and i believe it was 2006 just a few
months before i came on board from the
chicago history museum where i had been
for some time and i have to
um christopher missouri it is he's no
longer at iit
a very uh interesting individual
christopher stewart and
again you cannot gain say his import to
all this
um had a high sense of
commitment to truth um for him a library
is not just
a space it's not just a kind of a
meeting place and it's not just simply
a dissemination of information it's a
place where
people are invited to to look at
evidence and to verify truth
he had very much a sense that
truth is a contested zone and of course
we
nowadays in the era of um
you know trumpism we we tend to see that
now we recognize that but
christopher had a sort of foreboding of
that
history didn't end with the fall of the
berlin wall in 1989
we all kind of hoped it it would that
things would
uh usher in a period of amity between
east and west and that those rivalries
would be gone
but unfortunately the yugoslav civil war
in the 1990s uh 911 in 2001
uh and um the hardline
iranian leadership in 2003 445
under uh president ahmadinejad really
revealed that
truth was still going to be contested
that narratives could still be
warped and shifted and christopher
stewart was very
determined to make sure that people
could judge for themselves
read the transcripts hear all of the
audio interviews have all of that
out there and once he became dean in
2006 he
he moved that project forward from just
a small sampling of materials to
as much of the audio files as he could
put online and as many that
in all of the transcripts in translation
and in transcription that he could could
muster
and so the second iteration of the um
site went up in 2009 and yeah if there
was something of a
a real sort of um
uh again something of a real philosophic
commitment
that christopher stewart had to that
which was very exciting to work with
uh in terms of that for me
professionally it was very fulfilling
because i
came with a history degree in european
studies not just
u.s studies and to be able to support
that effort
um again
that notion of contested space that
we we live in as john kennedy said in
1961
a period of hard and bitter peace we
still are in a period of heart and
bitter peace
where um we need to stand up against
demagogue
populism and we need to really commit
ourselves to
robust platforms where evidence is
at the foundation uh so that um
at least people of of of good a good
good will and of commitment to truth as
we understand it in academe
could strengthen themselves and carry
forward
uh dr boater's message which was
and still is his legacy lives a
commitment to
the truth let history and let the world
be a judge of his work
and let it be a judge of what actually
did did occur
so um i'm gonna turn it over to adam but
that's
that's my contribution on that
thank you mindy um so i'm gonna talk
a little bit um about the current state
of the voices of the holocaust project
i will give you a kind of sneak preview
of the new version of the site that
we're working on now
and kind of discuss what we're hoping
this
new move can kind of bring to the
material and
people's experiences with it
let me just share my screen here
okay um so this is
the voices of the holocaust site um as
mindy mentioned
that was put up in 2009
and this was voices of the holocaust as
it existed until very recently
the site was of course
generated a lot of traffic we you know
we're
constantly chatting with folks about it
interested
holocaust scholars high school students
you name it um so it was a very popular
site and we knew that
but we also knew that it was beginning
technology wise to get a little long in
the tooth
and the point at which we knew we needed
to make a move
was when web browsers started disabling
flash technology by default this meant
that essentially to get any of the
interviews to play
on a modern web browser you had to know
where to go to tell it
that it was okay to use flash so i i had
an email
copying an email that i copied and
pasted i don't know how many times
explaining
to people how to do this and it became
clear that this this just wasn't tenable
um we also knew that the the text
encoding initiative tei
format that was used to encode the
interview translations and transcripts
wasn't quite it was it did its job
really really well but it wasn't as
interoperable
with modern web technologies in terms of
video playback
and audio and text synchronizing and
we were kind of kicking around some
ideas we had a
few of my colleagues um were working on
some demos of some things that might
work and that's when
steven approached us about the idea of
adding the
voter interviews into the aviary
platform so they could sit alongside the
fortune of archive interviews
and not only was the idea of bringing
these all together
a great idea but we realized after a
little bit of exploration
that the aviary platform could
serve as a a way to
kind of service the technological
underpinning of
the new website so this
is the interviews as they look in aviary
[Music]
and i'm kind of playing around within
the illinois institute of technology
collection here but as steven mentioned
these interviews will come up in a
search right alongside the fortune of
archive interviews so you know there is
a
there's a real kind of connection being
made here
that just wasn't there before for the
boater interviews um
so if we look for the aforementioned
uh mr silverhart you'll see that
you know maybe maybe his fortune of
interview i should have done this search
ahead of time but i decided to improvise
based on previous content
but regardless um you can see here
that interviews are popping up next to
each other and this is
to my knowledge the first time that
the voter interviews at kind of a you
know word by word level
have been kind of taken out of their
silo
um so then i'll give you a brief demo of
where we're at now
um starting with the the apology that
this is
visually this is very bare bones at this
point this site we've
most of the work we've undertaken to
this point is of more of like a
technological and data migration
efforts we have not done a whole lot in
terms of design
so take that in mind as i as i kind of
drive through here um so this site is
built in
drupal using a software called islandora
these are two platforms
that we were already working with and
committed to
so it became a very natural way to do
this
and we migrated we tried to migrate
every little bit of data
that we had from the previous site over
to this one
there are a handful of things we're
still working on integrating
um but that meant a lot of
a lot of media remediation that had to
happen by hand
especially because aviary wanted data in
some way
formats island dora wanted it in others
and so a good bit of my time over the
past six to eight months has been spent
kind of
going hand by hand through these
interviews at times and i will echo what
mindy said about it
it's been very gratifying and
intellectually stimulating work at times
but not
not always the easiest thing to spend uh
spend my day going through especially
during a pandemic
um so there was some interesting times
uh this summer for me um
so i want to just briefly kind of
make a little run through things here um
and talk about
some of what this site will provide that
the older site didn't
so the the search and browse interface
is
a bit more a bit more in line with what
a modern internet user is going to look
for
including things like faceting so i can
take the interviews and say well i only
want people in their 20s
and you know people in their 20s that
were born in greece
and so it's very easy to kind of
narrow in on partic a particular
interview or a particular set
of interviews um we of course
have searching by terms and so if i'm
looking for
any of the interviewees who say worked
in a factory
or talk about work in factories i can
then again do this
this same sort of narrowing down
to find what i'm looking for um we're
working on this knowing that some folks
are going to be coming
just kind of interested in the idea of
this project
and not really looking for anything in
particular but there will definitely be
scholars
who are looking to find some very
specific things
in these interviews and we want to try
to allow for both um
so within the interviews here you can
see that it embeds
a player window from aviary
into the site here and we have
and you'll see that my the search that i
did there is represented here and i can
actually jump
directly directly to those so we're
trying to make it as easy as possible
for people to get to what they want to
hear
and then i can
immediately jump to this spot in the
audio and i'll just let this interview
play for just a moment
i wouldn't be alive anymore because this
personal world would be still to give
out from here to the page anything for
the work
nothing well you needed something
so for to get to know it
and we didn't get anything from that the
gas wants a little bit of soap
and we had to work ourselves only with
water
and oh yes we got one piece of soul
but that wasn't enough and how did you
handle your laundry
so that's an example of how how someone
looking for a very specific thing can
kind of
hopefully access it as quickly as
possible
another really important part of this
project that
i think has something to do with
the kind of the the idea
that stephen was talking about earlier
and
alan and mindy have all mentioned this
this idea of connecting
connecting this work um and
one of the things that is has been
fairly big
in kind of web projects of this sort
over the past
i don't know decade or so is this idea
of linked open data
and this idea that
all of these data points within these
interviews are things that other people
in other projects and other places are
also referencing
and so one thing that we tried really
hard to do is to build on
already i don't know how many hours of
work done kind of laying that
laying the groundwork for this in the
initial site but we tried to as much as
we could and there's still a handful
that i'm
playing with a little bit here link
link out records for any camps people or
places
to online authorities and
to try to do things like represent uh
represent which
camps were subsidiaries of others
simple things like which cities are in
which country and you can now
kind of bounce between a city look at
every city mentioned in that country and
jump over to those um and then we have
we also have a way to represent
you know here's every interview that
gross rosin is mentioned um
so there's there's also a very
uninteresting
kind of underpinning to this that my
colleague tim floor is going to work on
that will allow people to kind of access
this data under the hood
let's say and
you know that way if you know the one of
the big things in
in projects like this over the past you
know
five to ten years has been people
building these portals that give you
kind of access across a spectrum of
institutions
or projects and this will
also the work that tim is doing is also
going to make that possible for these
voter interviews that we
will be able to hand someone a you know
a
figurative bucket of data and have them
loaded into their system
that will hopefully allow us to point
people
to these interviews and to have people
find them without
already having to know they exist
because
up until now a lot in a lot of ways you
would have to know that the boater
interviews existed to find them
and it is our goal to make that not so
necessary
um you know i one other thing i wanted
to
quickly point out um you know i
the the work that alan and others have
done to
contextualize voter's work um and to
tell his story
is you know i will speak for myself but
i think i can speak for us as an
institution it's
you know it's not something that we
would be able to do and we've
we've tried to take a just the facts
court sort of approach to this and allow
others to
kind of expand on that story where they
have the expertise to do so but
we we have been able to include things
like
voters annotations that were present in
his transcript
as well as for selected interviews we
have scholarly
annotation and commentary and we've
included that as well
but for the most part we have not done
any additional sort of contextualization
outside of the the kind of linking to
authorities and that sort of thing
um it's something we're not adverse to
but we did not feel that we were we were
in a situation where we could do that
now
in terms of what's left to do on the
site there's still a little bit of
research work i have to do
on town names and things like that
that people said and maybe voter perhaps
didn't transcribe correctly and so for
decades it's been a little
a little foggy i don't i don't claim to
say that i will be the one to figure it
out but
trying to do my best obviously there's
some design and aesthetic work to be
done here
and then a lot of the work under kind of
beneath the surface of this that's going
to make it really interoperable with
other other portals other projects
that's work that's ongoing as well uh i
wish i could say that we had a great
date set as kind of the relaunch for the
voices of the holocaust project
but today we don't um this
unfortunately is not anyone's uh
full-time project right now and as i
think anyone
anyone can attest to over the last six
to eight months it's been
it's been difficult but we're hoping
early 2021
the site will be ready to go and
uh until then if you if you navigate to
voices.iit.edu
it will it will bring you to our
collection in the aviary platform so the
the interviews
are still accessible um all of the
annotations
and the metadata for the interviews the
descriptions the commentary
it's all there um but hopefully
within the next few months we will have
the site done and be able to present it
in the format that we think makes it
most usable um
and also you know
hopefully most enlightening to our users
and i think that's it thanks
thanks adam and thanks mindy the site
looks that's the first time i've seen
the site with the
aviary embeds and it looks very good
it's very exciting to see that
um okay we have a few questions
in the q a uh tab here so i'm going to
to just read them off for alan
um this one's from
shira lily with schmidt uh does the
religious or non-religious identity of
an interviewer make a difference
if so how does it impact on the
interview thanks for the question
uh boater was
a traditional eastern european jew
so it was very important that he could
actively speak six languages
and had passive knowledge of three
others
um he wasn't a
he wasn't a religious jew in the
conventional sense
so when he interviewed
uh those who were
which took place the henneville
interviews
and other places um
he tried to cope
um and
so there's uh there's a gap it makes a
difference
but uh what we have is his
uh eliciting a chronicle and commentary
from the interviewers
religious or not not
conventionally religious and uh
so he he did what he could
i i don't want to say more than that
generally stay
i'll stay within the voter interviews
okay uh another question this one's from
joanne rudolph
why do you you think it's desirable to
popularize
david voter's work since such
popularization has the potential to be
more harmful
and helpful
that's a great question joanne thanks
um
i think that
popularization brings
a
brings knowledge and awareness
and can
already plant the seed of an idea that
someone
conceived of
taking such and steps to an expedition
to listen to people that he had no
connection with
so i think that can be very inspiring
for those in their daily life
as well as for uh
for academics so i think voters
initiative
was so
inspired and
resourceful that
it has the possibility
of bringing that inspiration more
generally
so that's why i think it's important
okay um another question from oren steer
uh he is intrigued by the notion of
public listening
that's something that you if he
understood correctly you you spoke about
public listening in your
presentation what might public listening
look like in practice both academically
and more generally today
thanks warren for that
searching question so
just the beginning thoughts on that
on that notion and look forward to
conversing with you about at a greater
length
so i think that the focus is often as i
mentioned on public speaking
that through one's education one feels
uh pressured to
speak well express oneself well
and that takes uh that takes precedence
uh listening can also bring
a very very great results
as i think voters uh interview show is
the
fort north archive display
so public listening i i was thinking of
in a sense that
was not speaking about listening
in terms of a private activity
that one does
on the telephone or with a friend
but rather in a way in a classroom
in a lecture in uh
seeking uh to illicit
information and a chronicle from those
who have gone through
difficult experiences
so public public listening would
have that kind of
grooming of the skills of listening that
would see them
as a very
important perhaps even crucial part
of education
and also ethical life
that's yeah great answer thanks alan uh
and uh one more question from joanne
this one
is for adam uh how can you begin to
judge quality
potentially scholarly annotations is it
risky to include these in terms of your
institute
having to judge the quality of the
scholarship
that is a good question um and it's a
point at which
uh you know mindy spoke about
christopher stewart
and his his the importance that he
placed on the truth
um and i some of the other folks from
galvin library that worked on the
project
uh evan english is another another
foreign
former galvin staffer who did a lot of a
lot of work related to this
and you know every indication that
i have gotten from anyone uh including
mindy is that they they did this very
scrupulously there was a there was a
committee set up
um that was kind of the scholarly
support committee for the project um
and so all of all of the commentary and
all of that kind of extra extra context
that we're bringing
in we're reproducing what was on the
site before
um and you know i am aware that to some
extent me saying
we're taking what was there and putting
it putting it there again
is a little bit of a cop-out um but as
as your question correctly indicates i
am certainly not in a place to feel that
i can
i can judge this um
and you know really um
to some extent we we kind of hope that
the folks who really really know what
they're talking about
are going to be using the site
interacting with the site
and offering suggestions and commentary
uh axel delsman who
alan mentioned earlier who indeed is a
wonderful resource pertaining to boater
in all of his interviews and has done
some amazing work
he and i had some really interesting
conversations
about you know kind of the data we had
and the site we had and
things that he was doing at his home
institution and ways
they were expounding upon some of what
was in the interviews
um and we we would love to do
kind of a full bore scholarly review of
all of that we're not at a place right
now where we could do it
unfortunately but you know in the future
perhaps we can so really i'm i'm
standing on the shoulders of
christopher and evan and mindy and
kristen and people that worked on this
project previously and
i owe them a debt of gratitude as well
as stephen who again
i just want to point out without his
kind of enthusiasm and support
this whole version of the voice of the
holocaust site
would not be perhaps not the accident at
all or at least it wouldn't be what it
was
so just want to make sure i say that as
well
thanks adam um okay
we've definitely gone a little bit long
and
speaking of public listening this was a
exercise in public listening
um so uh i appreciate everyone
uh everyone who came and and stayed with
us to the to the end
um if there are any other questions you
for for adam or mindy or for alan that
didn't
feel comfortable addressing uh now you
can always send them to me
and i'll pass them on by email um but
thank you again
um to alan and to mindy and adam for all
of your work
and congratulations on 10 the 10 year
anniversary of
um of your book allen it's still a
wonderful
a wonderful piece of scholarship and it
continues to sort of
uh impress uh our work
at the fortunate video archive and
impact our work
so i i appreciate you being here okay
and with that we'll bid everyone
ado thanks for coming